once he has lost everyone and everything
he values I will drive an arrow through
his eye hey youtubers it's Charlie since
arrows coming back next week I wanted to
do a predictions video for the second
half of season 2 we actually already
know a few things like the arrival of
the Suicide Squad Slade and brother
Bloods super soldier army whenever my
weekly episode review start again I'm
also going to be doing Q&A videos the
next day so if you have big questions
for each episode you can just leave them
in the comments for those review videos
and I'll put them in my Q&A videos on
the next day be sure to subscribe to get
everything so let's do our top 10
predictions for arrow this year number
10 there's gonna be a lot more slate in
present-day the mid-season finale
revealed what Slade has been up to and
now we're gonna get a lot more Slade
scenes off the island including learning
what happened to him between the time he
left the island and when he started
working with brother blood number 9 the
League of Shadows will return with a
vengeance the Canary basically
bitch-slapped them whenever she killed a
Lawal and Malcolm Merlyn is on their
list
so Starling city has this giant red
bullseye painted on it number 8 will
meet Ra's al Ghul's other daughter Nyssa
al Ghul will also learn how she's
connected to the canary remember how
Allah Wall said that the child of Ra's
al Ghul awaits your return it implied
that Sarah had this deeper relationship
with her it could be a BFF situation or
they could have been friends with
benefits or Assassins with benefits not
really sure how it works in the League
of Assassins number 7 the Suicide Squad
will become the Suicide Squad we've
already met the new Amanda Waller and
her shadow organization Argus and we saw
Diggle set Deadshot free so it's only a
matter of time before Waller forces him
to join their team the other confirmed
members of this version of the Suicide
Squad include bronze tiger played by
Michael Jai White and the newest member
is going to be the clock king played by
Robert Knepper you probably remember him
as the villain from heroes Sean Maher
from Firefly is actually gonna guest
star as blast radius but we don't really
know what's gonna happen to him at the
end of the next episode so he might not
end up joining the team there have even
been rumors about a Suicide Squad
spinoff but they haven't really
introduced a few of the key characters
that they would need like Harley Quinn
number 6
Oliver will train Roy and it will be
hilarious
Oliver is famous for punishing people
physically I mean he did learn from
Slade so
that ROI is supercharged and almost
indestructible Oliver's going to punish
him in the most hilarious ways trying to
turn him into a superhero number 5
Thea will learn about team arrow she's
going to notice what's going on with Roy
and that will kind of clue her into what
Oliver Felicity and Diggle are up to
most of her action will revolve around
the Malcolm Merlyn storyline and she
will end up helping their mother and the
league get rid of him notice I did not
say kill Malcolm Merlyn I do not expect
Malcolm Merlyn to die again this season
lazarus pit for the win number 4 Oliver
and Felicity still will not hook up a
lot of people keep asking me what the
deal with Oliver and Felicity is they're
basically like a married couple that
does not have sex the showrunners have
said that Oliver will continue to have
chemistry with multiple women meaning
that he's going to continue to hook up
with a bunch of different girls like
Summer Glau and probably some of the new
gift stars I wouldn't be surprised if he
ends up hooking up with the daughter of
Ra's al Ghul whenever she shows up
Batman did it with Talia and Oliver is
basically an analogue of Batman in the
arrow universe number 3
Batman will not have a cameo on the show
I know a lot of you really want to see
Batman or at least Bruce Wayne guest
star but DC is so protective of that
character that it's nearly impossible
they're not going to cast a different
Bruce Wayne right after announcing Ben
Affleck as the movie version of the
character
there's even an upcoming episode that
features someone who's a billionaire
from Gotham City we're almost guaranteed
that someone is not Bruce Wayne the
flash is basically the biggest new
character we're going to see this season
with one exception
number two Barry Allen will not cameo on
the show again but he will be mentioned
and he may end up helping them from
off-screen because the plans for the
flash TV pilot changed Grant Gustin is
working on his own one-hour show right
now so instead of coming back in episode
20 like he was supposed to we're just
gonna see that first episode of the
flash I'm predicting that they'll show
it to us way in advance and if we're
lucky we'll get to see it before the
summer comic-con at the latest the arrow
team did an awesome job of showing off
new stuff at last year's Comic Con so
they're not gonna stiff us this year
whenever they really want people to get
behind this new show and my number one
prediction we'll see a very brief Ra's
al Ghul cameo and in the finale we'll
learn more about Nanda Parbat this is
more of a longshot but we'll get to see
that place where Malcolm Merlyn says
death doesn't mean anything aka
the Lazarus Pit that doesn't mean we're
going to see one of the villains climb
out of a Lazarus Pit but we'll learn
more about how arrow is going to treat
the idea of the Lazarus Pit here's the
bonus prediction - Slade will not die at
the end of the season they didn't kill
Malcolm Merlyn after season one and
Slade has a super regenerative
properties given to him by the mirakuru
serum so he wouldn't even need a Lazarus
Pit
unless Oliver beheaded him and Oliver is
probably going to try and atone for what
he did to Slade and shadow on the island
so he's not gonna want to kill him don't
expect them to be friends anytime soon
though but it would be cool to see them
forced into a team-up situation you know
like if Darth Vader and obi-wan got
stuck fighting a third villain and had
to briefly team up before they started
fighting each other again I wonder who
that third villain could be hmm just
speculation but let me know what your
biggest prediction is for the second
half of arrow and what do you really
want to see in 2014 I know we all want
to see the flash in that red suit we all
want to see Ra's al Ghul we all want to
see a Lazarus Pit let's all cross our
fingers and hope it happens so like I
said arrow comes back next week so my
regular weekly reviews will start again
be sure to subscribe to get them also be
doing q and A's every Thursday morning
for that too so get excited it's gonna
be a lot of fun right now click here to
get my top 10 moments from arrow last
year and click here to learn how Coulson
survived after the Avengers that's right
they finally revealed how Coulson lived
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives
you